I have been speaking in the last lectures about the ending of part one,
uh,
of the Quixote.
And today we finally get to the end of the novel.
Uh,
I remind you again that although you have both parts bound as one book,
we all have bonus one book.
Uh,
this is the end of the novel set Avantis set out to write that he had no
specific plan to write the second part,
which would not be published anyway until a decade later in 16,
15.
It's very easy,
uh,
to make the mistake that what we're coming to now is a provisional ending.
Uh,
so,
uh,
avoid that mistake.
Uh,
it is very easy to make because of the book being bound together and also
because of the very nature of the ending of part one is so,
uh,
complicated.
Uh,
it is also easy to fall in that mistake because you know that part two is coming
as part of your course and that you're going to read it,
but not the readers of the 1605 Quixote in 16,
oh five did not have a second part that they knew they were going to read.
So I want to dispel the notion that this is a provisional ending.
This is the ending of the novel.
I said Avantis uh,
conceived it.
There are critics who seem to see in the ending,
uh,
hence that it around this planned a second part,
but there are a,
they are a best,
uh,
hints because second parts were often written,
in the 16th century.
Second parts of chivalric romances had many parts.
The cell is,
Dina had many second parts.
They last Saturday you had second part's the goose vondale.
Farace also had a second part.
So it is a conceivable to do see in some of those hints that possibility dot.
Cervantes thought of writing a second part,
but it is not part of the plan of the 16 or five key holiday,
which stands on its own or was the assigned to stand on its own as a book.
It is almost impossible,
uh,
to buy it today,
separately,
of course
now ending the Horta is a difficult thing to do because it is no ordinary story
with a clear beginning that is the birth of the hero for instance,
and a linear plot in which the protagonist pursues a goal that he either
attained or fails to attain Hennessy's defeated or he dies.
It is not a love story like the subordinate stories that we have just seen being
resolved at the inn in which the lover's get married and presumably live happily
ever after.
Mickey Hotel,
as we have seen from the start,
from the prologue to be specific,
is a metta novel,
Metta novel and novel about the writing of a novel.
Among other things like,
um,
kind of met Archie Valerie romance in that it is a parody overachiever,
Valerie,
a romance novel.
It's a novel that includes and all about the writing of the novel.
This is quite common in avant garde fiction in the 20th century,
but it is the first time that it happens in the literature in the Quixote to
have this,
this,
uh,
dimension,
of,
of criticism of the novel,
uh,
included in the novel itself.
So,
uh,
so the business of bringing it to a close is a complicated one that involves
closing several narrative strands plus the commentary or mid and novel part
about the composition of the novel.
Can I just come to the end and say the hero fail,
died,
got married?
No,
no,
no.
You still have to deal with all of these,
uh,
commentary on the writing of the novel,
which is part of an hour.
How do you end that?
How do you close that?
Um,
I want to,
uh,
I will anticipate that you have already read that ending because the only
possible ending to that narrative level is the prologue.
Okay.
With all of its hesitations about how to write it,
which means with all of the problems about how to close the book,
the last episode of that Meta fiction or level is the prologue.
MMM.
Because,
uh,
closing the book,
which we literally do when we finish has many implications.
The most important of which is that it implies or includes a statement by just
doing it about the structure,
about the shape of the book.
Endings,
as I've mentioned,
are very important.
And I believe that I mentioned the best book on the subject,
uh,
by frank mode with a k kermode the sense of an ending.
So brief,
but very,
very smart book that I recommend if you're in the literature that you pick up
Sunday,
Sunday on read.
So closing the book actually got to the end and you close it as many,
uh,
implications about the,
the,
it's a statement about the structure of the book,
the very fact that it has an engine that you can close it.
These are the reasons why we do have several endings or closures and why the
prologue has to be the final or overarching one,
which necessarily suggests circularity and self enclosure.
If you come back to the beginning and make it the end.
Um,
and this secularity and itself self enclosure,
uh,
we saw is one of the characteristics of their normal,
the Quixote,
which is a fiction based on fictions and in which there are,
uh,
oh,
there seem to be no way out of a fiction because even the very author whose name
is on the cover is contained within that fiction.
Miguel.
They said Advantis it's contained in the scrutiny of the books.
Remember his novel,
like Galatia is mentioned.
And then,
uh,
they saw me that I wanted this away,
that I was in the capitalist.
Stale.
That's one of rant.
This is last names.
So he's also an allusion to himself during kinetic or Toledo.
The story that you read for today,
because I said the story that is contained,
so even the author whose name is stamped on the cover is within the,
the fixture.
So I will discuss several episodes that constitute partial endings,
but reminding you that the ending is the prologue.
The first of those episodes has to do with the enclosure with the enclosure of
Don Quixote.
I'm playing with the word and closure,
by which I mean he's caging,
caging,
Don Quixote's a little form of closure.
You close it in,
it takes him out of circulation for good as the character that he invented
himself to be.
So I'm seeing even in the act of and closure of the character,
a form,
a kind of ending,
a formal enclosure.
Now don't get hotter.
It's an outlaw.
As we saw in the arrest order read by the,
uh,
holy Brotherhood trooper.
Remember the one who can read very well,
who apprehends him after they freakers at the end,
being a criminal,
uh,
others,
particularly the priests have to argue Don Quixote's case to prevent the Holly
Brotherhood from taking him prisoner.
Remember,
his crime is against the crown because the galley slaves were under the purview
of the crown.
So he would've,
he would have been taken by the Holy Brotherhood,
arrested and perhaps even executed.
Remember the Sanchez at some point that he can hear the arrows of the holy
Brotherhood buzzing around his ears because of course,
sanctuary in a commoner is more a to be arrested by the holy brotherhood.
Where else do you hope to be in?
And he got to go perhaps thought that he was above the law.
But in any case,
uh,
the other,
the priest particularly have to argue,
uh,
that Don Quixote,
be,
uh,
released,
sort of,
uh,
on their cost,
in their custody,
releasing to the custody because the,
the priest argues very persuasively like a lawyer,
uh,
being insane.
Don Quixote,
they would never be kept in jail,
would never be convicted.
The insanity defense existed in Spanish law since the 13th century.
So,
uh,
an insane man would be released.
Yeah.
Again,
again,
look,
not that's insanity puts him above or beyond the law.
It is his most significant characteristic as a literary character and being
insane.
He accepts no law,
but why is it caged and not simply arrested and taken home in shackles
sitting on a [inaudible]?
Why is it that at the end of the health is freedom has to be denied in such a
spectacular fashion.
And I mean spectacular because it's caging of Don Quixote and his caring being
carried home in this cage is a spectacle.
There are two plot strands that are winding up here.
First,
donkey,
hottest quest,
and second,
the priest and the barbers own quest to return to return him home,
possibly to be cured.
This is what justifies the charade,
uh,
of the masks.
Pragmatically,
the forest is staged because if don't get hot,
the recognizes the barber.
I'm the priest.
He will catch on about the plan to return him home and he might resist,
but there is more to it.
It is really only at the level of fiction that donkey halted.
The character that he himself has created can be captured alone.
So he,
no,
the uh,
the dial go,
they're modest in,
I'll go from that place in la,
man.
Jack can be arrested or apprehended,
but not donkey holiday who is,
uh,
an invented literary character or less.
It is within the world of his fiction.
Hence the make believe.
Okay.
And this is the,
the scene of the caging.
In page four 15 of the Jarvis translation,
they made a kind of cage with Poles gradewise large enough to contain don
Quixote at his ease.
This is the bottom of page 15 and immediately Doki hope they and his companions,
we don't lose the servants and the officers of the Holly Brotherhood together
with the innkeeper all by the contrivance and direction of the priest covered
their faces.
And these guys themselves some one way,
some another so as to appear to Loki harder to be quite other persons or those
he had seen in that castle.
This being done with the greatest silence.
They entered the room where Don Quixote,
La fast asleep and not dreaming of any such accident and laying fast whole of
him,
they bound him and a hand and foot so that when he awakened with a start,
he could not stare,
not do anything,
but look around him and wonder to see such strange visa charges about him.
And presently you fell into the usual conceit that is disordered imagination was
perpetually presenting to him,
believing that all these shapes were gobbling.
So that enchanted castle and that we thought all doubt,
he must be enchanted.
Since he could not stern or defend himself all precisely as the priest,
the projector of this strategy and fence it,
it would fall out central alone of all that were present was in his perfect
census and his own figure.
And though he wanted,
but little of being infected with this master's disease jetty was not at a loss
to know who all these counterfeit goblins were,
but he did.
He does not open his lips or delete.
So what he surprised with what,
what his surprise,
uh,
an imprisonment of his master meant talking about century.
Uh,
the irony here in this episode is that Don Quixote has communicated to the
others the freedom to act out whatever fantasies they have.
Isn't this contradictory?
He is caged for giving them,
allowing them the freedom to cage him in a way he has contaminated them with the
imaginative freedom that he practices.
This theme began with the story of Dorothea becoming Princess Mikami corner and
her acting out at you,
Valerie romance invented on the spot by the priest and performed by her as the
priest invents his whole charade.
This whole charade,
which is like a brief theatrical piece or interlude taking place in the darkness
of the inn is like the episode of a nightmare.
Don Quixote Awakens to find himself bound on,
surrounded by what seemed like gobbling support him in the cage was,
is this a dream or is this reality is a dealing here,
uh,
said run test with a theme that was a very common in the 16th and 17th centuries
and that was made famous in a play called life is a dream by a playwright called
[inaudible].
You may have heard of it.
This is a play from the 1630s,
but you can see that the theme is,
uh,
is here,
of
real life or is this a dream?
He has gone from being a asleep to finding himself surrounded by this strange
figures,
uh,
in,
in the darkness of the ins of what could it be if not some sort of a nightmare.
So he leaves as his enchanted in the cage.
Donkey Horta is like the prisoner.
He is in the sense that because prisoners were paraded through the streets as a
lesson to other prisoners were routinely,
I think even up through the 19th century paraded through the streets of towns in
cards or,
or,
or walking,
being flogged and so forth.
As a,
as a,
as a lesson to other,
part of their punishment was,
was uh,
their punishment being made public.
So he was not unusual for them to be broadly mostly writing a donkeys and stuff.
They were paraded through the towns,
but also in carts.
Um,
he is also,
uh,
like a circus freak show.
That's what,
uh,
shows and you will see one a or two in part in,
in the second part of the chaotic traveled around in carts.
And in fact a place where,
uh,
staged in carts in the,
in the,
in town squares throughout Spain.
That is the company came in the cards and the cards opened up and became the
stage.
So,
uh,
the cart here is,
is,
is an important,
uh,
and significant means of communication of taking Gnocchi around as a prisoner
and also as some sort of a freak show.
It continuation of the theatrical episode of the terrain to,
uh,
to put him in the cage.
So this emphasizes that theatrical quality that I,
uh,
that I,
mentioned.
An important part of the terrain is the prophecy contrived and delivered in
dramatic,
highly affected tones by the barber,
which for tells of the future of Don Quixote has night projecting a potential
ending to the story on that fiction or level,
which satisfies no Quixote like the priest.
The Barber is an author,
but also an actor besides I cannot do justice in my,
particularly in Jarvis is 18th century English and with my Cuban accent.
But uh,
this is the,
uh,
the prophecy by the,
by the barber [inaudible] four figure.
Let not the confinement you are under a flicked you for it is expedient.
It should be.
So for the more speedy accomplishment of the adventure in which your great valor
has engaged you,
we shall be finished when the furious Manchego and the lion shall be coupled
with the white turbos and dove after having submitted their stately next to the
soft matrimonial yoke from which on heard off conjunctions shall spring into the
light of the world.
Bribe Brave Webs who shall emulate the tearing Clauss of their venues.
Sire.
And these shall come to pass before the pursuer of the fugitive nymph shall have
made two rounds to visit the bright constellations in his rapid a natural
course.
And though,
oh the most noble and obedient squire that ever had sore in sorting belt,
beard on face,
on smelling nostrils,
be not dismayed.
And our afflicted to see the flower of night.
Aaron tree carried dose away from denies for ear long before long is so pleased
the fabricator of the world,
thou shall see myself so exalted on sublimated that Thou shall not know thyself
and shall not be defrauded of the promises made thee by Thy Noble Lord.
And I assure you in the name of sage,
it mean Ddo Niana mentored Ranjana from the word in Spanish,
men Theda for lie.
This is the,
the sage that die wages shall be punctually paid thee as thou will see in
effect,
fall on there for the footsteps of the Valeros and enchanted night where it is
expedient for you to go where you may both rest.
And because I am permitted to say no more God be with you for I return,
I will know whether,
so this is the prophecy invented on the spot and delivered by,
uh,
by the barber who is,
as we can see,
uh,
quite,
quite a ham himself and also quite able to imitate the speech of [inaudible],
uh,
romances.
This is the peak of play acting in the chaotic,
by the way,
you can see in the prophecy that this is a projected ending of the novel that is
Donkey Hotel Lucy.
Now we'll marry and have children and so forth.
So you see,
this is the projected ending within the fictions of,
of,
beyond even the fictions,
uh,
Don Quixote has invented.
So this is yet another level of those levels that the novel,
uh,
shows throughout,
created by characters.
This is the peak of play acting in the Quixote culminating performance than
that.
Among other things displace Cervantes,
his talents as a playwright,
but particularly a playwright of the interviews,
the funny skits that he wrote,
one Paloma is in,
which has been used as a court of no,
and I said debating meeting room where they debate what the base in is and so
forth is now transformed into a theater as don Quixote is finally dismissed from
it.
These two is one of the endings.
So the 16 or five Quixote and the novel has several as I mentioned.
And as we saw in the last class when I discussed the restitution made,
uh,
excuse me,
we have a visitor in the class and insect who is crawling in the middle of the
room and uh,
who ma,
uh,
I,
this is,
uh,
an added show free of charge,
by this,
uh,
by this bug.
Uh,
Elena,
maybe you can capture it.
Shall we kill it or not know?
What is it?
The,
it came out of Toby's bag.
Well,
I'm sorry.
if you can possibly,
uh,
pay attention to my lecture.
Hmm.
So,
uh,
yes,
please,
please let,
let us make a pause here.
Uh,
an interlude while Toby,
the vulnerable
delivers us from this monster
who is very elusive.
It seems
we've got four,
he doesn't crawl up your pant leg.
Is your film all of this
okay.
As it Kelsey is leaving the area.
Oh No.
Oh,
grab with your hand.
Thank you.
Justin Q was,
I had planned it.
So,
uh,
so this is one of the endings of the 1605 Quixote.
And the has several as I mentioned.
And as we saw in the last class,
we discussed the various restitutions to those who had suffered damages.
This ending is the most consistent,
uh,
the prophecy with the fictional world generated by Don Quixote and now inhabited
by all the characters around him except for central,
who knows what is going on,
but prudently chooses not to intervene.
Okay.
So now we go on the road on,
we meet one of the most memorable characters in part one,
the Canon of Toledo,
who is traveling with a retinue and meets,
uh,
these very strange caravan carrying in Don Quixote and stops to find out what
this is all about.
And after he does,
uh,
they,
the Canon Doki Hilton,
the priest engage in a,
in a discussion about commonplaces of literary theory about the romances a of
chivalry.
Uh,
and about the,
uh,
mostly,
Aristotle's poetics.
Uh,
now the relevant background texts.
Here are the philosophy and p poet.
Deca.
Bye.
Okay.
Alonzo Lopez being Siano known as [inaudible] Siano.
Uh,
1596.
In Spanish we write philosophy or today with an f,
that's just the old fashioned spelled.
Okay.
And Lopa the Vegas out of 10,
where will they,
instead of [inaudible] 1669,
which is of course Polish after the Quixote,
but which deals with topics that are very relevant to this episode.
Um,
philosophy,
antiwar Attica is a book in which helping Siano x pounds,
uh,
literary theory mostly derived from my risk Donald's poetics.
And
now,
uh,
it is one of the great ironies of literary history that Cervantes was wildly
innovative in narrative fiction,
but exceedingly conservative in the theater except when writing is brief,
comical interludes.
I don't have to emphasize now how he was wildly innovative in narrative fiction
about the theater.
Uh,
this episode is a vicious critique of Lopez.
The Vega is enemy Lopez Omega because Lobelia Vega wrote plays that will not,
that would not,
did not follow Aristotle's a poetics,
the rules of a unity of action and the place and have time.
Everything had to happen in one day,
in one place,
and there was 21 plot and,
and,
and so forth.
Uh,
Lopez flaunted all of this,
uh,
rules on his place where,
historical place that,
uh,
that,
where dubiously accurate about the history.
He just made it up like Shakespeare.
Uh,
he was a,
a great innovator who wrote thousands of place and,
uh,
who couldn't care,
couldn't care less about the rules.
Uh,
he invented the Spanish national theater,
uh,
by not following the rules.
Uh,
but there were those like Cervantes himself who criticized him for that.
and he replied in 16,
oh nine in this very hilarious poem called the,
uh,
the new art,
about how to make place at this time.
The,
the,
the title is very polemical that you can see out of art is supposed to be
eternal.
And he says,
new art do art is an oxymoron.
Art cannot be new or old.
It's always the same.
Supposedly if you follow,
uh,
the poetics,
red comedies at this time now,
not in the past now.
And so a Lopa was wildly innovative and he,
uh,
as I've mentioned before,
just,
uh,
took over the Spanish theater and said,
Vantis
plodding place that followed the politics,
did not have much success.
He,
he,
he did write an and have had a few stages it staged and then he had the
interviews,
also a stage and a book of,
of these appeared.
And I would speak about that when I speak about the transition between the first
and second and second part.
But it is the,
uh,
an irony that said,
run this.
It was so innovative and the pros was so conservative.
So he's using,
of course,
the,
the cannon and the priest to criticize local yoga for all of this irregularity
just in his place.
Uh,
Peter Russell,
who's a very reputable English [inaudible] scholar writes quote the discussion
among the three characters,
um,
about,
you know,
a theory has little bearing on the kind of discoveries about fiction that's
Advantis has been making empirically in his book,
hardly a word he said in it,
for example,
about comic writing.
It is true.
I think that Russell,
he's right.
That's advantage considered all of the theoretical issues that kind of put
forth,
but that in practice he did not adhere to any of them except,
uh,
that have various,
the militude that the novel does not deviate from the mutation of nature.
That is,
character's never engaged in supernatural actions and that actions,
uh,
under there no actions that are beyond the credible,
that is very similitude.
Uh,
they're most interesting.
Part of the discussion is when the and hope they explore the possibilities of
the romances of chivalry,
which in the end the Canon winds up pricing because they afford the possibility
of introducing variety,
which is a one,
one renaissance,
uh,
principal does Advantis did follow besides the cat on himself confesses that he
has written the,
the first hundred pages of evolve Vallourec Romance.
Uh,
this is hilarious.
He is,
uh,
the critic of few violin rig romances.
So this is a typical Savante and twist.
We have seen that it was the priest who read out loud the novel of the curious
in pertinent and hear the cannon since I myself replied,
the cannon was once tempted to write a book of night,
Aaron Three in which I purposed to observe all the restrictions I have mentioned
and to confess the truth,
I had gone through above a hundred sheets of it.
And to try whether they answered my own opinion of them,
I communicated them to some learning and judicious persons who are very fond of
this kind of reading.
And two other persons who are ignorant and regarded only the pleasure of reading
extravagances and I met with a kind of a probation from all of them.
Nevertheless,
I would proceed no further as well in regard that I looked upon it as a thing
for into my profession as,
because the number of the own wise is greater than that of the prudent.
And though it is better to be praised by the few wise than mark by a multitudes
of fools,
yet I am willing to expose myself to the confused judgment of the giddy vulgar
to whose lot of the reading of such books for the most part,
for
they key hot a donkey Hartej,
uh,
for his part us in reply,
makes up a Valerie interlude based on the story of the night of the lake,
just wide remarkable.
And it's with which in a sense he wins the debate,
uh,
both accounting and the Quixote,
our offers as,
as,
as the barber.
The,
the priests and so forth.
Uh,
now there is a very elegant joke in bedded in all this discussion.
Um,
the cannon I maintain is the idol reader.
Uh,
the district,
the Torah that's Advantis addresses in the prologue,
remember that he really says this [inaudible] idal reader.
Uh,
the,
the joke is that canons were supposed to have cushy jobs that allowed them time,
the time to read and develop themselves to other leisurely activities via they
can only go
was
and still is the way of saying cushy life
panels were in charge of reading Canon law.
They were in charges and there were supposed to read Canon Law and pass her
judgment.
I kind of always church law that is,
uh,
when we talked about incest and the prisoner of sex,
who would determine what is insist and what is not whom you can marry and whom
you cannot marry and worry is a sin and noticing and so forth.
Uh,
Canon law is very,
very important.
It's not to us anymore.
Uh,
and the separation between crime and sin is beginning in the 17th century and
doesn't really,
it's not quite accomplish until the 19th century,
if you know what I mean.
But cannons had all the time in the world to sit around and read and so there
was supposed to be,
you know,
well fed fat and they were capable.
Uh,
then they had the time to read romances of chivalry and pass judgment assists.
All of these figures of authority in Cervantes are always slightly ridiculous.
Uh,
um,
uh,
they have some floor or another,
but here is jet,
another author,
another internal author.
We have seen many in the [inaudible] a donkey,
how to himself,
the priest,
the Barbara,
we just so she knows the Pasa Montay CDMA telling Haley,
uh,
the translator,
we have a resource to them or Cardenio,
uh,
and so forth.
That Quixote is literature within literature,
literature with its own internal rules discussed not from the outside.
This is what is important here.
The characters are discussing the nature of the work within which they appear
there is to say that there is a seamless continuity between theory and practice.
At the level of discourse,
but not at the level of ideology.
That is to say the novel does not comply with the theory propounded by the
Cannon of Toledo,
but flows from within it's own practice.
Notice that the Canon has not finished the novel that he begun,
and that he also confesses that he's never finished.
The reading the novels that I began reading,
it never gets to the end.
Uh,
I think that's a fantasy is pointing out here,
uh,
the difficulty of finishing a novel and finishing this novel in particular.
Uh,
and that is more important than all the commonplaces about Aristotelian theory
that the characters discuss a little background on,
on Aristotelian theory,
although,
um,
I think that the best thing to,
uh,
to,
to approach,
uh,
this,
passage of the Kingdom of Tornado,
which of course has generated a lot of criticism because all you have to do is
give a scholar a set of rules that were being propounded on a novel on scholars
think that art is written following rules.
It is a dilution of,
uh,
of scholars and critics.
Uh,
but none of these theory can contain the narrative,
the experiments in narrative that we have been observing indic Quixote,
all of the various levels of fiction.
Uh,
all of these intertwined stories,
all of these very wild and at the same time disciplined experiments about the
nature of fiction that we find in the Quixote.
All of that surpasses any theory that,
uh,
that,
was,
uh,
expound that,
in the,
uh,
Spanish golden age in the 16th century or in Europe,
in the 16th,
uh,
sanctuary.
So we cannot be here a blinded by,
by,
by the philosophy,
Antigua,
poetic carbide,
Aristotle's boy.
It takes by Plato and all of those discussions because the poetics of the
Kihatha are contained in its own practice,
not a,
and it's,
some practice includes the discussion of its own politics,
but it did,
it does not take the theory from outside and applies it to the Quixote.
That would be a foolish what,
what happens in the 16th century,
uh,
in,
in literary theory in the 16th century is the,
the,
the world worn debate between Plato and Aristotle.
Plato was the first spoil sport in the history of criticism because he thought
that art was,
uh,
a negative influence in the republic.
And he wanted to banish the ports because art,
uh,
appealed to the emotions.
And because art was based on imitation,
it couldn't be a itself,
it was always any mutation or a of something.
Uh,
so,
uh,
although,
neoplatonism as important in other realms of 16th century,
uh,
literature,
that view of,
of art and poetry,
uh,
was countered by Aristotle's,
a critique of,
of Plato in which he departs from the,
uh,
by his point of departure is his baseline is that humans are,
tend to imitate.
Imitation is part of the human condition and are therefore,
uh,
art is inherent in the human animal because he imitates and it's,
we are all Mikami.
Micardis if we remember that Princess,
we gonna be gone.
I was about Emmy Tatio boss about me,
Macy's.
Uh,
we are all,
uh,
monkeys,
mutate a,
we imitate just like monkeys.
And this is what Aristotle really propound said,
imitation,
uh,
is a good thing.
And that in mutation,
uh,
in art leads to a pleasurable in intellectual,
pleasure of an intellectual process that he favors that is at the base of
Aristotelian theory.
Now I startled then in their politics,
gives a series of rules that the basis on his own practice of reading the epic
and the theater,
uh,
that is applied or the lady Shirley,
sometimes in the renaissance,
the renaissance,
a penchant for,
uh,
reviving the classics.
That is basically what is at stake here is parallel to what I mentioned in the
last class about the rules of government that are being drawn up.
Then from Machiavelli on,
it's very much a part of,
uh,
of,
of the renaissance who tried to draw up rules and the rules of behavior that,
uh,
we're containing Baldessari Castiglioni,
the coacher.
Uh,
these are all parallel movements,
but in the case of the Quixote,
uh,
none of this theory,
is ultimately relevant.
It is contained within it.
It is discussed,
uh,
but uh,
it is,
it does not drive the book and it's not drive,
uh,
it is not control.
The poetics of Samantha's is poetics.
In the Keyhole,
which surpasses all of that,
uh,
by quite a bit.
So I will not,
uh,
expound very much beyond that.
On the,
uh,
on the,
the precedence for installers,
poetics.
Uh,
there's a lot of criticism and one of those who has written eloquently about it
is,
uh,
easy.
Riley who,
uh,
who you have met in your,
in my case book in the essay about life and art and so forth in Oklahoma.
He has written a book,
he wrote a book,
he died not too long ago,
Riley,
um,
about,
uh,
the theory of an oval instead Cervantes,
his theory and all that,
which is a classical [inaudible] criticism.
Uh,
but I think that ultimately what I have said here today,
it takes care of it now.
So lantus is of course,
expounded on literature and,
and,
uh,
in other books,
he has a long poem called [inaudible] boy used to buy mass,
which is a book of literary criticism about the,
the,
the literature of his time and in the prologues through his various books he
expounds on,
on criticism,
uh,
and uh,
and so forth.
Uh,
but the problem is,
uh,
as with all writers of fiction,
that's advantage
has this theory of peer always in dialogue,
in a dialogue among various character.
So you cannot really pinpoint him of what is what,
what's the rant?
This is preferences in all of this,
but I think that the,
the,
the points to remember is that the kind of is a slightly ridiculous,
ridiculous figure that we cannot take him as a figure of authority who has given
us deploy.
It takes over the Quixote by any means that he himself has tried to write a
romance of Javari.
Now,
another element that express it in this episode is the critique or the criticism
of the romances of jewelry.
They were criticized severely in the 16th century by and figures as important to
us,
Erasmus of Rotterdam,
another one of these renaissance figures that I have mentioned before,
uh,
Beavis and others criticize the romances of chivalry for there being potentially
a,
I'm a bad influence on society,
uh,
in terms that that Cervantes echoes mockingly India Quixote when he says that
he's written the book to do,
are worried with the romances of chivalrous.
So there was,
uh,
there isn't this episode too also an echo of those debates about the romances of
chivalry because as I mentioned,
they were quite popular at one point,
uh,
aided by the fact that they could be,
they were printed and distributed in relatively large numbers,
large numbers for the period.
So this is what,
this is what is at stake in these episodes involving the Carnival Tornado,
uh,
which I think are also preparing us for the ending of the book,
which as I said is the prologue.
It is one of the,
the most sustained takes on the poetics,
uh,
of,
of the,
of that you've ordered romances and on point the and literary theory in the,
uh,
in the audit.
So the important thing to remember is very similitude surrenders,
never deviates from very similitude.
That is,
uh,
the characters never engage in anything that is supernatural or do something
that is beyond what common sense would,
uh,
the common sense of a normal reader who would,
would allow so much for this episode,
which is,
uh,
which has,
as I said,
I listen to it a lot of cases.
It must,
you can imagine and that I find very entertaining because a,
I think that the figure of the candidate is really a very funny one.
You will see that,
uh,
religious figures,
appear in that cohort.
They,
well,
the priest has been around the whole first part.
Others will appear in part to,
uh,
one in particular who is depicted in,
in,
in very negative terms.
As you will see that Canon is not the kind of,
is a very learned,
very well read and,
and funny in a his own contradictions.
Notice of course that the whole debate takes place over dinner,
I mean over lunch or whatever.
This picnic that they have organized in this Nice Valley with food that they
have obtained from the [inaudible] and these locals or manuals where we will
find a pastoral interlude.
Uh,
we just another one of those stories that repeat previous ones towards the end
of the day,
it is again a way of lending substance to the book by this inner references.
The episode is like a new version of the resource Domo and Marcella episode,
but it also recalls parts of some of the intertwined love stories.
Leandra is a young beauty in her father's care who is desired by many men and
how many of the goat herd and unsettle him.
Another goat herd Alejandra's principles,
suitors.
They appear to be perfect candidates to marry her as in the earlier story of
Crisostomo and Marcella,
they're both well off and so forth.
Then there appears to be sent in a La Rosa who rules her with his wireless and
lies,
uh,
Bill because underwrite is no Marcella.
She allows herself to be seduced by the center that are Rosa,
who is a modern man in that he has made himself almost literally the way that
he,
that he uses a three sets of clothes.
He has three suits and he shuffles them in such a way that it appears that he
has many and he is Emilio Glorioso,
Terman Latin,
Eh,
uh,
self glorifying a soldier,
soldier Mueller's Lordosis from classical comedy.
This is a solely who goes around boasting of all of his great feats of arms and
showing scars that he has from battles as,
as,
uh,
as he does us be centered.
A La Rasa does here he plays the guitar and so forth,
and this is a way that he woos her.
They run off to the wild,
the same kind of landscape that we found in the Sierra Morina where she's robbed
but surprisingly not sexually ravaged,
which is a Q,
a curious detail that I have not been able to ever to understand.
What does that reveal about you sent on Rosa?
That,
uh,
I mean,
it may be as bad as that he was impotent and that all of these don't,
one like,
uh,
adventures that he seems to be engaged in a really a,
a cover for that.
But I find it amazing that she has been left untouched,
uh,
and that,
that satisfies her father very much,
but the story is left on finished.
It hasn't,
it hasn't concluded.
No one knows what it's going to happen.
And I wonder,
I have under why.
And I think that the reason is that we are now coming to the end of the novel
and what it's being narrated is kind of a precedent and a present cannot have a
conclusion because,
uh,
current events or current,
not,
uh,
and to,
to bring them,
to give them a conclusion is,
which is an artificial way of,
uh,
of,
of finishing them.
I think that's the only way to explain this unfinished story.
Uh,
that is just left on finished.
We come to the end.
Uh,
finally the priest Barbara Sanctuary,
no Quixote arrived back in donkey halters on a Sunday.
Is this significant?
It is the day of rest of leisure or feasts,
consonant.
Perhaps we don't get hopeless arrival in a cage.
A see we as if we were part of a affair.
But to me the most moving and interest in detail is that Don Quixote does not
know where he is.
If you go to page four 58 at the very end,
all this discourse at the top of page four 58 or this,
this course passed between Sancho Panza and his wife,
there is a panser.
You will see that her name changes throughout the book.
This is another one of the run.
This is careless mistakes.
She goes,
one I'm dear is and so forth.
While the housekeeper and the knees received donkey haughty and having pulled
off his clothes,
laid him in his own bed,
he looked at them with isis queue not knowing perfectly where he was
after all these adventures,
home is no longer familiar.
Do Don Quixote.
Uh,
it is not if it ever was the abode of the county,
but,
uh,
of the uncanny instead of curing him,
it seems to me bringing him home has made him madder than ever.
Perhaps the circularity of the event coming back again has made him dizzy to the
point that he cannot recognize even his own bed.
This is what I found very moving.
He's in his own bed and he can't even recognize it.
Now.
He will again get out of it,
although we would meet him in it at the beginning of part two,
but not quite soon in the fiction of part two.
He will get out of it.
But a long decade later in real history,
I was going to wind up today by talking about link it and cartel ego,
which we were supposed to read for today and I'm going to do very briefly,
but uh,
uh,
we will come back to be exemplary novels,
again,
uh,
to his cousin regarding quarterly or perhaps a little more and also because we
will be reading several of them.
is the date of the novella is a hymn Pladis called here.
This is the edition that you're using.
I assume exemplary stories.
It's impossible to find a good title for it because no veil loss at the time
meant short nols or long short stories.
But today we,
if we say exemplary novels,
do you think of La longer novels?
Short stories that were the,
the term didn't really emerge until the late 18th century,
early 19th century with the appearance of newspapers and all of that.
So this is why there is no way,
no good way of translating it.
And when does a Spanish speaker reads a today he's misled by the title in the
wheel as a him.
Pladis uh,
the point is,
I said Avantis became well known
because the Kihatha did so well and publishers were,
became interested in publishing his works for a change.
They had already fleeced him with the Kihatha,
so they were ready to do so again with other books.
So he was able to publish this collection of stories that as I told you in an
earlier class,
does not have the overarching fiction,
uh,
that,
that the camera on and other such books have all the characters leave the city
because of the plague.
Get around or get together somewhere.
And then each one tells a story on a different day.
This is the,
the camera on,
um,
uh,
fee over arching fiction.
This was an exemplary novelist.
Doesn't have that.
It is a one man show.
12 stories with a prologue by beginning the set of,
under this
set of anthesis.
I have mentioned favor the long short story.
Uh,
like the several ones we have encountered intertwining the Quixote and
individually in the novel of the curious impertinent.
Uh,
and uh,
he had a few in reserve.
Obviously us as we recall the papers that someone left at the,
in a one omega is in including at least a couple of stories by,
uh,
by said,
wow,
these were stories that were circulating in manuscript.
Remember that I told you that story is still segregated in manuscripts in,
in,
in spite of the development of,
uh,
of,
of printing.
Uh,
in the book he collects stories with varied diverse themes and styles.
It is like a series of narrative experiments,
some like [inaudible] or a keen to the picker risk,
others,
uh,
to the Byzantine Romance.
Others are love stories,
etc. We're going to be reading several here.
They are superb.
I think that even he of Andis had not published the Quixote.
He would still be,
will it become a major author by just this collection of short stories.
You'll see the glass graduate and all the others that we're going to read that
are really excellent,
excellent.
Uh,
stories now think are not deep uncle quarterly.
You is obviously a of a picaresque,
thematic and ambience and it takes place in the center of picturesque life.
Sayville
but he does not follow the autobiographical form of the bigger ask.
And that's said ranters made fun of through,
he needs to pass.
Amonte remember when he says,
look,
how can my life be over if,
uh,
having the book be over?
If my life is not over,
he's making fun of that.
So he does,
uh,
you will see that he does use it in the dialogue of the dogs at the end.
But you will see in what,
uh,
experimental,
fashion.
I to me the point is that [inaudible] don't buy the diminutive green Canadian
quarterly.
You become big curls because it is already a literary character,
a literary character.
Like so they become bigger as the same way that donkey hope that becomes a,
uh,
at you voluntary,
enact.
You could.
And uh,
there is,
there are hints of this in the,
in the first in when we learned that the,
the innkeeper of that first in had been a peaker and he tells stories,
uh,
un Un un,
are we getting the sense that some of these bigger roles that the innkeeper,
uh,
assembled within those Emporio vigorous life that I mentioned had chosen the
life.
It was not that they were just simply poor boys who were out looking for a way
of living,
but that they had chosen that life that they had,
as they said in the 60s,
in this country.
They had dropped out,
I said were dropped out of society to become a bigger,
and this is I think,
what is the case of [inaudible] and cartel,
who at the end decided not to be pickles anymore and that is the end of their
adventures.
It is not that they go to the galleys are their nab or they have to write a
story because they are married to the mysteries of an arch,
a priest and so forth.
As in alluding to [inaudible],
the Torah missed.
I think that the,
all the other very significant element here is money polios brotherhood money.
Paula is the chief,
uh,
criminal here who runs a whole brotherhood in very well organized fashion.
He's a,
again,
one of these figures of authority who is slightly ridiculous,
uh,
and he surrounded by a bevy of petty criminals,
prostitutes and pimps,
all of whom have their own features,
physical features that,
remember when I talk about the physical features and some of these characters,
and it is not a somber,
sordid life that is depicted as a speaker,
as Clive and the country.
It seems like a lot of fun.
Everybody is having fun.
The,
even the,
even the prosecutor comes,
uh,
complaining about her,
her pimp,
uh,
beaten her up at the end.
She actually reveals that it was really an s and,
m a Sadomasochist,
a little mutual game sexual game that they were playing.
So there's nothing evil in all of these.
Piggers is very much a,
so as I've told you,
even the worst characters,
uh,
have some good and I never totally evil and certainly none of these are totally
evil.
Um,
clip Alito is her pimp name and it is,
it means that he is bald probably from some venereal disease,
mean said what this deals with the,
with the most sorted but in a way that does not read as a sordid story.
And I think that,
uh,
I think also what is interesting here is that money polios Brotherhood seems
like the blueprint for society,
that it is the,
it is the,
the kernel of,
of society where rules are being created and where there is a kind of self
enclosed,
a atmosphere created by those rules as if this were the,
the,
this was the beginning of laws.
And the beginning of a certain mode of speech and so forth.
This is,
I think,
what is,
uh,
behind this breeze,
brotherhood is one of the renaissance topics about utopia.
This is a counter utopia.
And referring now to Thomas more,
another one of those renaissance figures that I want you to remember,
but you utopia.
What means is that he said,
well ordered society in which everything is,
everything has been thought of and advanced and there are rules and this is what
money polios brotherhood is like.
It's a counter utopia that is organized with the world rot,
uh,
sort of,
Polish of a work of fiction.
So we will return to this in,
uh,
our next classes,
which class,
which will come after Tuesday's exam.